[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans
scienceclic que verrait-on en approchant
la vitesse de la lumière
embarquons ensemble dans un vaisseau
spatial qui accélère depuis la Terre
vers l'espace
s'éloignant de notre planète de plus en
plus vite
que verrait-on en accélérant sans cesse
quels effets d'optique pourrait se
manifester et si l'on tenté de dépasser
la vitesse de la lumière en courbant
l'espace-temps comme dans les films de
science-fiction que verrait-on répondre
à ces questions nous servira à de
prétexte pour explorer de multiples
phénomènes de notre univers et nous
plonger au cœur des théories de la
relativité restreinte et générale
notre vaisseau spatial est initialement
à l'arrêt une fois avitaillé nous
commençons à accélérer
on imaginera que notre système de
propulsion nous permet d'accélérer en
permanence aussi longtemps qu'on le
souhaite
en prenant de la vitesse on s'éloigne de
la terre
en accélérant toujours plus on pourrait
penser que la vitesse du vaisseau
finisse par devenir insoutenable mais
non la vitesse n'a aucun effet sur notre
corps lorsqu’un train passe devant les
fenêtres d'une autre il est impossible
de ressentir si c'est notre train ou
l'autre qui est à l'arrêt de même à
l'intérieur du vaisseau nous ne pouvons
pas ressentir sa vitesse mais uniquement
son accélération la poussée des
réacteurs qui nous plaque contre nos
sièges
si cette poussée est raisonnable elle
sera parfaitement supportable tout au
long de notre trajet même à l'approche
de la vitesse de la lumière
il existe tout de même un risque lié à
la vitesse du vaisseau un risque de
collision à des vitesses très élevées
une simple poussière engendrerait des
dégâts colossaux en opercutant
heureusement notre vaisseau est équipé
d'un champ de force qui repousse les
objets dangereux et nous permet de
foncer librement à travers l'espace
à mesure que l'on accélère un premier
effet d'optique étonnant se manifeste
les étoiles devant nous alors qu'on s'en
rapproche semble peu à peu s'éloigner le
ciel se contracte devant nous
pour comprendre vous avez sûrement déjà
vécu la situation suivante vous êtes
dans une voiture qui roule à grande
vitesse et il se met à pleuvoir
la pluie tombe verticalement du haut
vers le bas mais comme la voiture avance
vous recevez les gouttes sur l'avant du
pare-brise de votre point de vue la
pluie ne semble pas provenir du haut
mais de l'avant comme si sa trajectoire
était inclinée et plus vous accélérez
plus elle vous semble venir de l'avant
dans notre vaisseau spatial l'effet
d'optique que l'on perçoit est
parfaitement analogue la lumière des
étoiles provient d'une certaine
direction mais à mesure qu'on accélère
les rayons lumineux nous semblent de
plus en plus venir de l'avant lorsqu'on
est en mouvement on voit les étoiles
dans des directions différentes c'est
l'effet d'aberration de la lumière
et puisque la lumière se focalise devant
nous l'intensité lumineuse augmente
tandis que derrière nous l'image du ciel
s'élargit et devient plus sombre
l'aberration de la lumière a pour
conséquence un autre phénomène étrange
imaginons que nous traversions une
immense grille représentant la trame de
l'espace
en temps normal on verrait une grille
rectiligne les traits qui la composent
apparaissent comme des lignes droites
qui filent devant nous par effet de
perspective
mais à mesure qu'on accélère au fil des
jours le phénomène d'aberration déforme
l'image du ciel tout autour de nous la
grille semble se contracter vers l'avant
et les lignes droites se courent
si l'on passait à côté d'un objet
immobile celui-ci nous semblerait être
légèrement tourné dans notre direction
c'est le phénomène de rotation de
Thérèse Penrose
comme on se déplace très vite les images
des objets semblent contractés devant
nous et la perspective est fortement
déformée
[Musique]
on entend souvent dire que plus on
regarde loin dans l'espace plus on
regarde loin dans le passé en effet la
lumière que l'on reçoit d'une étoile
lointaine a dû parcourir des milliards
de kilomètres ce voyage n'est pas
instantané il faut un certain temps à la
lumière pour nous parvenir
en conséquence on voit l'étoile telle
qu'elle était dans le passé au moment
d'émettre cette lumière il y a peut-être
plusieurs milliers d'années
qui sait si elle n'a pas déjà changé
depuis notre vaisseau spatial le même
phénomène est à l'oeuvre à mesure que
l'on s'éloigne de la terre la lumière de
la planète prend de plus en plus de
temps pour nous parvenir
si l'on pouvait zoomer avec un télescope
on verrait les personnes sur terre
évoluer au ralenti
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet Doppler
chaque tic-tac de l'horloge sur terre
prend de plus en plus de temps à nous
parvenir on reçoit les rayons lumineux
au ralenti et leur intensité semble
s'affaiblir tandis que l'image de la
planète tend vers le rouge
[Musique]
devant nous c'est l'effet inverse le
vaisseau rattrape la lumière et les
étoiles semblent de plus en plus
brillantes elles se décale vers le bleu
et leur horloge semble tourner en
accéléré
[Musique]
avec du matériel suffisamment précis
nous pourrions mesurer les phénomènes
d'aberration et d'effets Doppler dès nos
premiers jours dans l'espace
[Musique]
mais si l'on décidait de s'arrêter et de
revenir sur Terre ses effets n'auraient
pu aucun impact ils ne sont que des
illusions d'optique dû à la façon dont
on reçoit la lumière lorsqu'on se
déplace
mais après plusieurs centaines de jours
les réacteurs nous poussent toujours
plus vite et le vaisseau commence à
approcher la vitesse de la lumière
à de telles vitesse certains phénomènes
ne seront plus seulement des illusions
d'optique de vrais effets physiques vont
entrer en jeu et engendrer des
conséquences irréversibles la relativité
restreinte commence à intervenir
une première conséquence de la
relativité est ce qu'on appelle la
dilatation des durées
notre univers est un immense tissu à 4
dimensions l'espace-temps trois
dimensions d'espace et une dimension de
temps
dans l'espace-temps tous les corps même
immobile trace une trajectoire puisque
tous avancent vers leur futur
avant le décollage notre vaisseau
immobile se dirigeait dans la même
direction que la terre faire le futur
mais en prenant de la vitesse et on
s'éloignant de plus en plus vite notre
trajectoire a peu à peu dévié de celle
de la planète
[Musique]
désormais l'axe qu'on appelle le temps
n'est plus aligné avec l'axe temps des
habitants sur terre
si l'on décidait de faire demi-tour et
de revenir nos horloges auraient mesuré
des temps différents nous aurions moins
vieilli que les Terriens car notre
trajectoire dans l'espace-temps aurait
été différente
[Musique]
un autre effet fondamental de la
relativité restreinte et ce qu'on
appelle la contraction des longueurs
lorsqu'un corps se déplace près de la
vitesse de la lumière sa longueur est
contractée dans la direction de son
mouvement
depuis le vaisseau c'est l'univers tout
entier qui nous semble se déplacer vers
l'arrière pour nous l'univers est donc
contracté selon notre mouvement
en particulier la longueur du trajet
pour atteindre notre destination et plus
courte que ce qu'on aurait pu croire
attention cette fois-ci il ne s'agit pas
d'un effet d'optique mais bien d'un
phénomène physique et concret si l'on
tenté d'atteindre une étoile lointaine
le trajet nous semblerait réellement
plus court il prendrait d'autant moins
de temps qu'on se déplace rapidement
ainsi contrairement à une idée reçue il
serait tout à fait possible de parcourir
des milliers d'années-lumière en
quelques secondes dans le cas limite où
l'on se déplacerait quasiment à la
vitesse de la lumière tout traget serait
même instantané
pour les personnes restées sur terre
toutefois plusieurs milliers d'années se
seraient écoulés
[Musique]
la contraction des longueurs est un
phénomène bien réel mais visuellement il
serait difficile de la percevoir
pour comprendre pourquoi imaginons que
l'on croise l'orbite d'une planète
comme elle se déplace très vite vers
nous la planète est contractée dans sa
longueur
mais rappelons-nous plus on regarde loin
dans l'espace plus on regarde loin dans
le passé
par rapport à nous l'arrière de la
planète se situe plus loin dans l'espace
que l'avant de la planète
l'image que l'on reçoit de l'arrière de
la planète a donc mis plus de temps à
nous parvenir on la voit telle qu'elle
était dans le passé
en somme même si elle est contractée la
planète ne semble pas l'être
visuellement car on reçoit l'image de
son avant et de son arrière en décalé
plutôt que contracté elle semble être
tournée sur elle-même il s'agit en
réalité d'un phénomène que nous avons
déjà vu la rotation de terre rose
lorsqu'on se déplace très vite et que
l'on regarde sur le côté la tranche des
objets semble plus courte dans la
direction de notre mouvement
ceci peut s'interpréter soit comme une
contraction des longueurs soit comme une
rotation comme un effet de perspective
pour la même raison une personne qui
nous regarderait passer ne verrai pas
vraiment notre vaisseau contracté mais
plutôt tourné sur lui-même
[Musique]
au fur et à mesure notre champ de vision
continue de se contracter il
s'intensifie devant nous alors que tout
devient noir derrière nous
mais en accélérant de plus en plus on
pourrait s'attendre à atteindre à un
moment la vitesse de la lumière que
verrions nous alors
cette question est peut-être l'une des
plus fondamentales en relativité non
même si nous accélérons sans cesse nous
ne parviendrons jamais à atteindre la
vitesse de la lumière
pour cause la vitesse de la lumière est
absolue même si vous foncier derrière un
rayon lumineux de votre point de vue il
s'échapperait toujours à la même vitesse
la vitesse de la lumière
vous auriez beau accéléré tant que vous
le souhaitez même si depuis la Terre
vous semble rien approcher la vitesse de
la lumière de votre point de vue tout se
passerait comme si vous étiez encore
immobile et la lumière vous échapperait
inexorablement
il est donc strictement impossible de
dépasser voire d'atteindre la vitesse de
la lumière au mieux notre vaisseau
continuera d'accélérer pour toujours et
notre champ de vision se réduira de plus
en plus jusqu'à ne former plus qu'un
point infiniment brillant devant nous
entouré d'un ciel complètement noir
fonçant presque à la vitesse de la
lumière tous les effets d'optique
prendraient des dimensions extrêmes
comment rattrape la lumière dans la
direction de notre mouvement tous les
rayons lumineux nous semblent provenir
de l'avant
les rayons derrière nous quant à eux
nous nous atteindrons jamais
dans notre référentiel l'univers est
extrêmement contracté comme un fin tissu
que l'on traverse de part en part en une
fraction de seconde
pour une personne sur terre nous nous
déplaçons à la vitesse de la lumière
mais pour nous le voyage semble
instantané nous nous déplaçons
infiniment vite
pour conclure rien ne peut se déplacer
plus vite que la lumière dans l'espace
mais il pourrait peut-être exister une
façon très spéculative de contourner
cette interdiction en effet rien
interdit que l'espace lui-même se
déplace plus vite
[Musique]
la théorie de la relativité générale
nous enseigne que le tissu de
l'espace-temps est dynamique il peut se
courber de multiples façons on pourrait
ainsi imaginer créer une bulle d'espace
autour de notre vaisseau que l'on
propulserait plus vite que la lumière
c'est ce qu'on appelle en référence à la
science-fiction un word drive
il ne s'agirait plus de se déplacer dans
l'espace mais bien de propulser le tissu
de l'Univers lui-même notre vaisseau
resterait immobile surfend sur une vague
d'espace-temps supraluminique
une telle structure peut paraître
aberrante et on pense à l'heure actuelle
qu'elle est effectivement impossible à
réaliser un Warp drive nécessiterait de
courber l'espace-temps par de la masse
négative en quantité immense une forme
de matière qui a priori n'existe pas
dans l'univers
cela dit les mathématiques nous
permettent toujours de rêver et l'on
peut calculer ce que l'on verrait dans
une telle situation
vu de l'extérieur lorsqu'il passe devant
nous le Hard Drive semble apparaître de
nulle part la courbure de l'espace-temps
dévie la trajectoire des rayons lumineux
et forme une sorte de lentilles qui se
déplace et sein dans deux une qui avance
et une qui recule
pour cause la lumière voyage moins vite
que le Warp drive lui-même lorsqu'il
s'approche elle n'a pas encore eu le
temps de nous parvenir
et lorsqu'il passe devant nous on reçoit
en simultané cette lumière qui ne nous
était pas encore parvenue et les rayons
qui ont été émis plus tard
vu de l'intérieur nous verrions comme
avant un ciel contracté vers l'avant et
très brillant
dans notre dos l'univers semblerait
extrêmement sombre et toute une zone du
ciel semblerait avoir disparu la lumière
qu'elle aimait est trop lente pour nous
rattraper un cône d'univers reste
invisible derrière nous
[Musique]